We have a voicemail number.
That number is two.
One nine two.
David P received a number of voicemails and
emails related to my appendicitis.
Uh, it was great to hear from the ag man.
Take a listen to this.
Hi.
I'm just calling to see if David's feeling
better.
I'm worried about him.
Hoping a you at the hospital soon and hoping
you recover quickly.
Each fellow brother
shallow mag man.
Yes, I was, uh, out of the hospital within
a couple of hours of the procedure, I am feeling
significantly better.
Not 100%.
I'm told it can take even sometimes up to
two weeks to be back to 100%.
But working on it every day.
I also got some people believed they thought
peop there are people now who think that the
Bernie Sanders thing is a distraction and
that the producer Pat thing is a distraction.
Take a listen to this.
David.
This is Ralphie from Pella.
Hassey uh, just going to leave you a message.
Uh, my concern is this appendicitis thing.
Is it just a distraction?
Yeah, you're spot on.
It.
It's, it's absolutely 110% merely a distraction.
No.
But in all seriousness, thanks to everybody
who reached out on Twitter, email, Instagram,
Facebook, I heard from a ton of people and
I really do appreciate it.
And as part of my recovery, I am not doing
the bonus show today.
So producer Pat is going to have a fantastic
bonus show for you today.
Two ways to access it.
Become a member@joinpackmandotcomorapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].